So what's a single gal like you
doing rattling around this big
house? Well i assure you i'm married
to a man a human one...Wanda.
We are an unusual couple
oh i don't think that was ever in question
we just don't know what to expect
howdy neighbors hey buddy
wanda what's up who are you i don't know
i think something's wrong here
this is our home then let's fight for it
well i think we handled that well
Wandavision will be the very first marvel studio
series on disney plus wanda and vision are two
of our most powerful and complex heroes and
this series is a perfect expansion point for
mcu storytelling elizabeth olsen is currently in
london right now she's shooting the film doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness with director
sam raimi star benedict cumberbatch and the rest
of the cast including benedict wong rachel mcadams
and chiwetel ejiofor and joining them is a new fan
favorite character from the comics america chavez
played by sochi gomez this film hits theaters
march 25th 2022 and we're really pushing the
boundaries of storytelling with this thrilling
scary mind-bending adventure not only will doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness connect
directly to the events of Wandavision but it will
also connect to the events of our new spider-man
film coming to theaters december 2021. Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my new
Wandavision trailer they dropped so many marvel
trailers today kevin feige decided today was
trailer day there were also a bunch of star wars
trailers too so obviously i will do videos for
everything it'll probably take me a couple days
to get to them all so be sure to subscribe to
get everything it is going to be crazy marvel is
releasing 10 new disney plus series in the next
couple of years they announced what all them are
during their big disney plus investor day there's
also 10 separate star wars disney plus series
coming as well they even finally confirmed that
they're doing the fantastic four movie and it's
john watts the director of the spider-man movies
that's going to be directing it but just starting
with the Wandavision footage they confirmed that
the episodes are dropping starting january 15th
they're releasing one episode per week but they're
going through the decades of different sitcoms of
television and you can kind of see what's going
on with scarlet witch messing with reality and
things glitching out and how things go completely
off the rails by the end of the series when it
turns into a big avengers level action story
they said they kind of eased into that like it
starts out with the funny sitcom stuff happening
then it sort of spins up into bigger mcu avengers
level storytelling the whole premise being that
scarlet witch just cannot deal with vision being
dead like you see her sitting there on the couch
in her pajamas just not looking super hot and then
she starts rearranging things everyone remembers
house of m obviously there's a big house of m
easter egg during the trailer with the bottle
of wine maison do mapree house of contempt or
literally house of m as it says on the bottle
elizabeth olsen said that the series would be
taking a hard look at scarlet witch's mental state
so they aren't doing the exact comic book story
line but they're doing something very close to
it and as her mental health gets worse and worse
and worse and she just continues to spiral out of
control you see things start to glitch out which
is very similar to what happened during house of m
the reality started to crumble in on itself but
then you sort of see what's happening in the
real world while all this is happening inside her
tv-based reality you see randall park's character
from ant-man and the wasp roll in with the
agents of sword and darcy's character from
the thor movies we finally get a better look
at her in the footage so apparently she's also
working with sword right now too the reason
why the trailer is four by three aspect ratio
is because for some of the decades of television
television was aired in four by three aspect ratio
so they're just being authentic to the period
for each of the different parts of the trailer
they said that they tried to reference as many
different popular sitcoms from the different
decades but the ones they specifically
shouted out from the 1950s were i love lucy
scarlet witch talked about going full lucy
at times then in the 1960s they get into the
bewitch stuff although you do see her go full
samantha bewitch during different decades that
weren't during the 1960s like she's moving things
around cleaning the house using her telekinesis
so a lot of the tropes of the different
realities bleed into the other decades but
then they get the 1960s you have bewitch the
dick van dyke show that's where the joke about
the beds comes from because they were married
couple but on national television you weren't
allowed to show couples sleeping in the same
bed while the show was being aired then in the
1970s it looks like it goes kind of brady bunch
they also reference the partridge family that's
when she starts to get pregnant she's eating the
orange slices there you also see shots of the crib
with the butterfly mobile then turning into actual
butterflies as if it's her children turning the
butterflies into real butterflies those are just
her twins from the comics wiccan and speed so i
guess you're talking about deep cut x-men easter
eggs and mutants you'd be talking about wiccan
doing something like this the other twin speed
obviously has quick silver like powers when they
get to the 1980s it looks a little bit like family
ties maybe married with children obviously they're
referencing a bunch of different sitcoms but they
get to the 1990s it's full house she is one of
the olsen girls the olsen twins are her older
sisters so if you didn't know that elizabeth
olsen is related to them it's just that she's been
much more active in movies recently than they have
then kevin feige said that they also move into the
modern era of sitcoms in the 2000s and they do go
full office with people talking to the camera
like jim and pam and the other characters and
then filming things like a weird documentary so
there's a lot of easter eggs for television itself
in pop culture in addition to all the avengers and
marvel phase 4 easter eggs and x-men stuff with
mutants that are going on during the series too so
the series gets really meta with his easter eggs
the woman that she's talking to here is akatha
harkness obviously a very big sorceress from the
comics just like doctor strange as a sorcerer
she's been kind of a mentor to scarlet witch
in the comics but she's also been a bit of an
antagonist to her so we'll see what they do with
her during the series because you do see a couple
different scenes where the characters inside this
reality as they go through the decades start to
glitch out and don't know who they are or where
they are or what's going on that might be because
scarlet witch moves into this house in the normal
reality but then she starts warping reality around
them and it starts to pull in these other people
that live around her in this cul-de-sac you also
notice a lot of the design language too there's
a lot of patterns that look a lot like vision
circuitry so we're talking about being inside
a television it almost seems like during parts of
this she's reliving parts of avengers infinity war
in avengers end game like when she's staring
at the mind stone here that seems like she's
manifesting her memory of having to kill vision
during avengers infinity war to prevent thanos
from getting the mind stone even though he wound
up getting it anyway because he had the time stone
we also finally get a full scene with monica
rambeau we saw her in the last trailer now we
just get a much better look at her and the funny
thing about this is you've been a fan of hers in
the comics for a long time she was one of the
original versions of captain marvel the outfit
in the period that this is taking place in during
the 1960s 1970s is authentic to when she debuted
in the comics so her character is wearing an
outfit in this scene like she would have worn when
she debuted in the comics but like i said because
scarlet witch seems like she's messing with this
reality changing everything she's also changing
other people while this is happening so a lot of
their memories and personalities change while this
is happening so that might be why she doesn't know
who she is when she rings the doorbell but because
later you see her get kicked out of the reality it
seems like scarlet witch's energy is around her
so it seems like scarlet witch herself is the one
that puns her out because it sounds like monica
rambeau who is an adult in present day of the mcu
works for sword as well and she's probably trying
to investigate what's happening with scarlet witch
and why things are so crazy in this little pocket
of reality that's when you see all the sword stuff
spinning up and it seems like randall park and
the other characters are trying to help her but
she doesn't want to leave like this is our reality
let's fight for it as they say during the trailer
and then it turns into a big battle love all the
comic book easter eggs like vision walking around
in his halloween costume that's designed to look
like his classic comic book costume same thing
with scarlet witch based on the posters that
they released for this each day it seems like
this halloween stuff is happening during the 90s
era of the tv show they didn't say anything about
monica rambeau getting her powers during this
like her photon powers or becoming a version of
captain marvel or anything like that but they did
say after this she would star in captain marvel
2 along with the new miss marvel actress that
they just cast and they're shooting that series
they drop trailers for pretty much all the
upcoming disney plus series as well so what i'll
probably do is my next trailer video will probably
be for falcon and winter soldier and then i'll do
a loki trailer then i'll probably move on to the
star wars trailers as well but there'll be six
episodes of Wandavision she's gonna crack reality
in a really amazing way that's gonna cross over
with doctor strange to as kevin feige said during
the panel right now as i'm making this video
elizabeth olsen is over in great britain shooting
doctor strange too with benedict cumberbatch and
the other actors they also just confirmed that
america chavez is going to be introduced during
that she's miss america she literally punches
holes through different dimensions so obviously
you're doing a multiverse movie that would be an
appropriate place to introduce her they didn't say
exactly what she's going to be doing but she's
just another one of those younger characters
that they're introducing that could show up in
a young avengers crossover series down the road
and the really good news about falcon and winter
soldier is that they're releasing all the episodes
in march so there's so much stuff to talk about
for all the marvel phase 4 movies they confirmed
that they're going to do a war machine series
called the armor wars right out of the comics if
you haven't read that that's an actual comic book
armor wars the nick fury avengers spin-off series
is going to be a secret invasion series with talos
the scroll coming back and it's going to be them
going after actual scrolls that have infiltrated
american society the black widow movie is still
coming at the beginning of may then right after
that in may the loki episodes are going to drop
that'll also be six episodes then they're gonna
do the what if episodes that's the animated series
based on the what if comic book there'll be 10
episodes of that then they also confirmed that the
hawkeye episodes that they're filming right now
with jeremy renner and haley steinfeld kate bishop
will drop later in 2021 so like fall 2021 they
said a bunch about moon knight and not the other
series and some of the other upcoming movies but
i'll talk about that during those separate videos
so falcon and winter soldier will be the next
trailer but i've also got my mandalorian season
2 episode 7 video that will probably be my next
video then i'll do the falcon and winter soldier
trailer as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those videos don't
worry we'll get it all sorted out there's just
so much good news that they dropped today they
just decided to drop every last bit of footage
that they have for everything almost everyone let
me know in the comments if you spotted any big
easter eggs during the Wandavision trailer that
i didn't talk about and let me know based on all
the announcements what you're most hyped up about
while you wait for everything everyone click here
for my brand new spider-man 3 doctor octopus video
in toby mcguire andrew garfield and click here for
my brand new mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!